the united kingdom formally announcing
charles as its king today this says the
uk and much of the rest of the world
mourns the death of his mother queen
elizabeth ii you're looking at the scene
in london this morning where a second
proclamation of king charles has just
been read the king met with the
accession council earlier charles took
his oath and said he is deeply aware of
the duties and responsibilities of
sovereignty he's expected to meet with
political leaders later today on friday
he delivered an emotional address to his
nation promising to uphold the same
level of public service that his mother
the queen did during her 70-year reign
holly williams begins our coverage from
buckingham palace holly good morning
good morning while charles became king
immediately after his mother the late
queen died but today accompanied by his
wife queen consort camilla and the new
heir to the british throne prince
william his reign was officially
proclaimed this pageantry is all about
informing the nation it has a new
monarch with conventions dating back to
a time before there were telephones and
televisions to pass on the news
[Music]
this is how new british kings have been
officially proclaimed for generations
prince charles philip arthur george
is now
by the death of our late sovereign of
happy memory
become our only lawful and rightful
liege lord
charles iii
but it's the first time in history that
the ceremony steeped in tradition has
been broadcast live on television
i
charles iii
by the grace of god of the united
kingdom of great britain and northern
ireland charles may be in his 70s but he
has a reputation as a modernizer at
least within the confines of this
ancient institution
the new king is still grieving for his
mother the late queen
we owe her the most heartfelt debt
any family could owe to their mother in
his first address to the nation as
monarch he had warm words for the new
heir to the throne prince william and
seemed to hold out an olive branch to
his other son
i want also to express
my love for harry and megan
as they continue to build their lives
overseas
[Applause]
outside buckingham palace yesterday
charles was greeted by his people
[Music]
god saved the king some of them sang
it's this country's national anthem and
a wish for a long and successful reign
the coronation of king charles iii will
likely not happen for several months and
is expected to be held in westminster
abbey just down the road from here where
they've been crowning kings and queens
for over 900 years
jeff holly thank you very much